from the post-millennial
30 million Americans say violence is
Justified to keep Trump from Power
University of Chicago study the U
Chicago professor said the public is
more radicalized and that's really quite
significant Okay but well before we
opine on this let me read and write this
down because we got to be careful here
they say the study found that 11.6 of us
adults agree that a use of force is
permissible to prevent Donald Trump from
becoming president this amounts to
around 30 million people but hold on
there a total of
3543 U.S adults were pulled for the
survey in June of 2023 with a reported
margin of error of two to three
percentage points University of Chicago
Professor Robert Pepe or Pape who led
the research said that while he believes
recent indictments against President
Trump have created radicalization there
is also growing anger and radicalization
on the left as well oh gee you think
the public is more radicalized than it
was in April and it's really quite
significant we've been tracking this
quite a while and this is really a big
bump
what Pape did not mention is that the
amount is that the number of people who
would approve of violence when it serves
a desired political outcome on the left
dwarfs that of the right in the same
study was determined that the amount of
Americans who say the use of force is
Justified to return Trump to the White
House was shot uh has shot up from 6
million in the past few months to about
18 million it's almost half the amount
of people who justify using Vines to
keep Trump out of office so right now
when it comes to radicalization
I don't know if this actually means 30
million Americans it translates to
perhaps no they the these studies are
done in such a way that they have
successfully in many instances
extrapolated data to a great degree the
only question is margin of error they
say two to three percent maybe it's five
to ten ten to twenty let's say the
margin of error is 10 to 20 you think
that'd be fair Ian
um it's tough to tell it's impossible to
tell that's the problem with this
article and it's disgusting that they
wrote that headline that is complete
mislead because they only pulled 3 500
people but do you know polls work
yeah how do they work you get a small
group of people and then you ask them a
question or a group of questions and
then you can do whatever you want so the
way it works is they have charts
tracking various demographics they pull
the demographics in key areas they
figure out what the majority of these
areas think and feel then they do a
wider sample size of different questions
and say if the cast Castle household 80
90 actually 100 of this house everyone
pulled and it said they would not vote
for Joe Biden some might vote
libertarian some might vote Trump but
zero for Biden when they do a larger
poll and they say we called this house
and we were told that they don't think
violence is Justified they extrapolate
that with a margin of error to say
previous polls in the area based on
demographic views and and Studies have
shown that this group tends to vote this
way when we asked them they said this
they then Target a bunch of different
areas and say this 3 500 people is
actually a very large sample size for a
poll I think it's fair to say however
the margin of error could be way larger
and to just immediately say 30 million
Americans say no no we've extrapolated
that data point but it does suggest a
study suggests 30 million Americans
believe violence is Justified it doesn't
mean they will commit the violence
however just that someone else could I
think yeah if they were put on a jury
they would be like oh we sympathize with
what you did either way I think it is
absolutely fair to say this is patently
obvious when you talk to these people
and when you see people go and do men in
the street interviews with them they
they absolutely agree with this in major
cities
in a lot of places definitely I just
think that they should have done it by
percentage like this percentage of
people versus 30 million because that
makes it sound like there's exactly 30
30 million out here that are ready to go
to war right and it also says that the
study says that 30 million people said
it I mean this is completely misleading
discussion it could say 10 of pull
response 11.6 of Paul respondents said
that violence was justified there were
Millions
that's a big percentage uh our good
friends over at the post Malone I have
great friends with post Malone that is
disgusting you guys
30 million Americans did not say this
that's very very different uh but there
was a study that says 11.6 of those who
responded said they would
I don't think the study just went to an
antifa enclave or went to a DNC meeting
and said how do you feel I think they
did a standard uh you know study
let me uh what do we have political
crisis it's from July what what do they
explain can you go to the study does it
link to it it just links to a news
article
do we have this actually University of
Chicago because if they link to the
actual study sometimes that's
anger and radicalization Rising number
of Americans say political violence is
Justified surveys shows a small but
significant share of Americans believe
in the use of force to attain political
goals on the on both the left and the
right it's funny they don't mention that
the study shows that on the right it's
half of what the left wants so this is
from about two two and a half weeks ago
and uh let's see do they have the study
here dangers project has been conducting
dangers to democracy now they just
linked to another one of their own
stories
also if it dangers the Democracy survey
sounds like a pretty biased way of like
they're somewhere in danger you need to
get ready get going well to democracy is
a left biased title because Republicans
conservatives Libertarians don't call
the United States a democracy because
it's not yeah like would you fight if
you were in danger it's a lot bigger
question would you fight you know adding
the danger part of it is like well if
I'm in danger I'm going to be a lot more
likely to fight for myself so here's how
it should actually break down
if this was framed that way and it
skewed liberal in their survey questions
that means that of that 11.6 there's a
massive bias so the number is probably
much less among both groups in fact you
could argue if it's if it if it was left
biased then the political violence to
remove to support Trump would be a lot
lower you ask a liberal do you think
violence should be used to put Trump in
office they say no
do you think violence should be used to
stop Trump they say yes if you pull 2
000 Democrats and 1 000 Republicans you
will get the numbers you're looking for
that's the important thing to to track
with these studies but here's what I
want to get to
I don't know this is true all right it
may be one in five Americans believe
that the election is stolen these polls
are not always accurate sometimes they
are sometimes they aren't some of the uh
I mean but but what have they been off
by like seven to ten percent let's just
say the number is seven to ten percent
let's let's track all the polling that
we've seen thus far in the past two
elections from let's just take a look at
at 2020 and 2022 the presidential and
then the midterms the polling uh oh
actually 2016. let's look at from 2016
until now the polling has been
consistently off by between seven or ten
percent
so that means we're looking at 20 20
million people in this country with all
those sentiments if the polling was off
by that much and it could be in the
other direction it could even be higher
it could be 40 million people who
believe in use of force and violence but
when it comes to to plaintively telling
humans how many people want to fight to
kill right now we should be very
specific about who claimed that like it
was only 3 500 people that made those
claims so I do not want to extract 300
360 people of 3 500 people pulled so
it's very very very very very very tiny
and now considering that and considering
the polls have been wrong by about seven
ten percent in favor of trump I think it
stands to reason that the numbers
probably a bit less than 30 million and
we can argue that the 11.6 number is
probably if we if we were to drop it
down it's probably closer to nine
percent and also that's a high high
removal because I was saying just 10 but
that's that's nearly 20 being removed
from that number and people from 11 to 9
but so that then we'd be looking at what
15 20 million people who want to engage
in violence except a lot of people that
answer polls to begin with are people
that are politically activated and those
are the people that would be more likely
to in a situation you know take up arms
I think or people are already aware of
what let's say the amount of people that
want to engage in that are willing to
engage in violence is 5 million
let's say it's uh let's say it's two and
a half million
or three three let's just say one-tenth
of what the actual one-tenth of one
percent three million people I think
when you look at the summer of love it's
clear to see that there are millions of
people prepared to engage in violence
offensive violence I don't know they did
it yeah I mean you know hundreds of
thousands of people all over the country
I mean how many people I know that
during Occupy Wall Street they said
there were 300 000 at its peak had
protested in some capacity but this
ranges from actually sleeping in a park
to marching down the street a couple
times when it came to the Summer of Love
riots how many people actively rioted
what do you think 50 to 100 000 because
it was all over the country there had to
be hundreds in every city even small
towns
and there were multiple nights I mean it
wasn't just one right and then we call
it a day yeah fifty to a hundred
thousand
I don't know what I can tell you is we
had talked about this a long time ago
the amount of people required to
destabilize this country and and kick
off some really crazy stuff it's like a
couple dozen one we already know violent
crime is up in every major city across
the country we know that we are seeing
violence in a more regular basis than we
have in in years past so it wouldn't be
surprising to me that people would then
say like if I feel politically motivated
I would also be willing to act violently
uh that's that's a simple conclusion
draw I don't know what the number on
that would be it just seems like people
feel more unrest and are willing to act
out on that than ever before well I
think is interesting I feel like there's
a lot of violent people in the country
but to be like purposefully violent is a
like kind of a different thing right
like if you look at like what remember
then Kai sin that had that thing that's
his name right yeah and a bunch of
people's PlayStation giveaway yeah and
everybody started going crazy I think
that proves it to be completely honest
that it could happen yeah that that
we're on the cusp of it when people are
willing to be violent and destructive
for no reason you know people talk we
talk about Civil War and they're like
who's really gonna fight uh I don't know
a random guy who's bored because we've
seen that happen over and over and over
again in the past couple years people
just being like it's on I guess they
lose control and they go and smash stuff
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
or uncensored members only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time